>>> THERE ARE NEW MAJOR
DEVEPMENTS IN THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE JANUARY 6
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
AND THERE IS NEW REPORTING THAT
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HIS EFFORTS TO SUBVERT
THE ELECTION.
KEEP IN MIND UNTIL NOW, THERE
HAS BEEN ALMOST NO SIGN THAT
INVESTIGATORS WERE LOOKING
DIRECTLY AT THE ACTIONS OF TRUMP
POSITION.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST," PROSECUTORS HAVE ASKED
HOURS OF DETAILED QUESTIONS
ABOUT MEETINGS TRUMP LED IN
DECEMBER 2020 AND JANUARY 2021.
HIS PRESSURE CAMPAIGN TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION AND WHAT
INSTRUCTIONS TRUMP GAVE HIS
LAWYERS AND ADVISERS WILL FAKE
ELECTORS AND SENDING THEM BACK
TO THE STATES.
AND IN ADDITION JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATORS IN
APRIL RECEIVED PHONE RECORDS OF
KEY OFFICIALS AND AIDES IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
HIS FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS.
MEANTIME THE NEW YORK"NEW YORK S
REPORTING ON PREVIOUSLY
UNDISCLOSED Emails AMONG TRUMP
ADVISERS.
THEY WERE DISCUSSING THEIR
SCHEME OF FAKE ELECTORS AND THEY
ACTUALLY USED THE WORD FAKE.
SO THERE IS A LOT TO DIGEST
HERE.
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN.
AND JOINING US NOW IS COUNSEL TO
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS DURING
DONALD TRUMP'S FIRST IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
HE WAS ALSO THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE ETHICS CZAR.
AND ALSO ELIE HONIG, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE YOU BOTH.
NORM, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THIS
NEW REPORTING, WHAT DOES IT TELL
YOU ABOUT THE FOCUS OF THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, ANA, CLEARLY THE FAKE
ELECTORS SCHEME IS AT THE CENTER
OF THE WEB OF ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY ARE LOOKING AT BECAUSE,
COME ON, YOU CAN'T -- THESE ARE
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
YOU CAN'T FALSIFY OR FORGE OR
COUNTERFEIT OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENT.
>> HARD EVIDENCE.
>> IT IS A SMOKING GUN.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE Emails
WHERE EVEN THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ORGANIZING IT ARE CALLING THEM
FAKE ELECTORS.
AND WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE FROM
THE 1-6 COMMITTEE THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS PERSONALLY INVOLVED.
THAT VIDEO FOR EXAMPLE FROM THE
CHAIR OF THE RNC SAYING THAT HE
ASKED HER FOR HER HELP IN
GETTING THE FAKE ELECTORS
TOGETHER AND NOW WE KNOW FROM
THE "WASHINGTON POST" THESE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS ARE BEING
ASKED ABOUT TRUMP'S INVOLVEMENT
AS WELL AS MIKE PENCE, HE COMES
IN TO THIS SCHEME BECAUSE TRUMP
WANTED PENCE APPARENTLY TO USE
THESE PHONY CERTIFICATES TO BLOW
UP THE JANUARY 6 MEETING OF
CONGRESS AND BLOCK THE GENUINE
ELECTORS.
SO THE STRANDS OF THE STORY ARE
STARTING TO COME TOGETHER.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE INTERESTED
IN.
>> AND YESTERDAY WE REPORTED HOW
IT WAS PENCE'S CHIEF OF STAFF AS
WELL AS ANOTHER PENCE AIDE WHO
HAD TESTIFIED BEFORE THE DOJ,
TODAY WE'RE GETTING WORD THAT
OTHER WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS HAVE
ALSO BEEN CONTACTED BY THE DOJ.
BUT EVEN IF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS ASKING DETAILED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS OR ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHICH THE "WASHINGTON
POST" IS REPORTING, YOU SAY THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN TRUMP
IS A TARGET, RIGHT?
>> CORRECT.
AND SO THINK OF IT AS SORT OF
DIFFERENT STEPS IN THE CHAIN
HERE.
THE FIRST STEP IS ARE THEY
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU.
AND I THINK WHAT IS REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT THE NEW
REPORTING, WHO IS GOING INTO THE
GRAND JURY.
THE FACT THAT IT IS MARC SHORT
AND GREG JACOB, THEY ARE MORE
INSIDERS THAN ANYONE THAT WE
KNOW OF WHO DOJ HAS SPOKEN TO SO
FAR AND OF COURSE THIS MORNING
ALYSSA FARAH SAID THAT OTHER
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ARE IN
CONTACT WITH DOJ TOO.
BUT YOU START WITH ASKING
QUESTIONS.
IF THE INVESTIGATION PROGRESSES
TO A CERTAIN POINT, THEN A
PERSON CAN BECOME A TARGET
MEANING SOMEBODY WHO PROSECUTORS
BELIEVE IS REASONABLY LIKELY TO
BE CHARGED, THEN YOU MOVE ON TO
AN INDICTMENT AND THEN OF COURSE
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE OF ALL IS
CONVERTING AN INDICTMENT INTO A
CONVICTION.
SO IMPORTANT BUT VERY, VERY
PRELIMINARY.
>> WHAT WOULD INDICATE THEN THAT
TRUMP IS A TARGET, WHAT ARE YOU
WATCHING?
>> SO IT COULD BE A COUPLE
THINGS.
DOJ SOMETIMES SENDS PEOPLE
TARGET LETTERS SAYING DEAR
DONALD TRUMP, WE NOW CONSIDER
YOU TO BE A TARGET.
THERE IS SOME DISCRETION IN
THAT.
DOJ DOESN'T ALWAYS DO THAT.
BUT THAT COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS.
WE ALSO NEED WATCH WHO ELSE GOES
IN TO TESTIFY IN THE GRAND JURY.
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE MORE
REPORTING ON THAT.
SO THERE WON'T NECESSARILY BE
ANY SPECIFIC MOMENT IN TIME
OTHER THAN IF THERE IS A TARGET
LETTER BETWEEN NOW AND WHAT
COULD BE AN INDICTMENT.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND WAS ASKED ABOUT A
POSSIBLE INDICTMENT OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT OR EVEN A CANDIDATE
FOR PRESIDENT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE PURSUE JUSTICE WITHOUT
FEAR OR FAVOR.
WE INTEND TO HOLD EVERYONE,
ANYONE, WHO WAS CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EVENTS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6 FOR ANY
ATTEMPT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
LAWFUL TRANSFER OF POWER FROM
ONE ADMINISTRATION TO ANOTHER
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> SO I HEAR THAT AND I FEEL
LIKE THAT HAS BECOME HIS GO-TO
RESPONSE.
BUT NORM, I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
GARLAND.
YOU SAY YOU HEAR A LEVEL OF
INVEST
SPECIFY ICITY IN THAT AREA.
>> YES, WHEN HE SAYS THAT HE IS
GOING AFTER ANYONE WHO
INTERFERES WITH THE LAWFUL
TRANSFER THE POWER, IT IS A
MOSAIC OF EVIDENCE.
BUT YOU KNOW, ANOTHER WAY TO
THINK OF THAT IS LIKE A JIG SAW
PUZZLE.
WHEN THE IMAGES START TO EMERGE,
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE INCLUDING
GARLAND USING THESE WORDS FOR
THE FIRST TIME SUGGESTS TO ME
THAT THERE IS ONE PERSON WHO WAS
WE NKNOW IN CHARGE OF
INTERFERING, THE PERSON MOST
RESPONSIBLE UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION FOR THE LAWFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER, WE'VE NEVER
SEEN A PERSON IN THIS OFFICE DO
THIS BEFORE IN THE HISTORY OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THE EX-PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
SO I THINK THAT THOSE WERE
SHARPER WORDS THAN WE'VE HEARD
BE
BEFORE.
OF COURSE WE HAVE TO SEE WHERE
WE GO.
BUT I THINK THAT THE INDICATORS
ARE POINTING TO SEVERE LEGAL
PERIL FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY THIS STUFF
ALWAYS TAKES TIME.
THERE IS ANOTHER ELECTION RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER.
MERRICK GARLAND SEEMED TO
INDICATE THAT THERE WAS NO TIME
FRAME THAT HE WAS GOING TO HAVE
TO BE PIGEON HOLED TO.
BUT IS THERE A TIME CRUNCH?
>> WELL, THERE ISS IS A PINCERS
MOVEMENT ON DONALD TRUMP.
THE FEDERAL INVESTIGATION I FEEL
CONFIDENT WE WON'T SEE CHARGES
IF THERE ARE ANY AGAINST TRUMP
IN 2022 BECAUSE OF THE PENDENCY
OF THE POLITICAL SEASON.
IN GEORGIA THOUGH, TALK ABOUT
TARGET LETTERS, WE HAVE A
PROSECUTOR, THE D.A. FANI WILLIS
WHO IS DOING A PARALLEL
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE OF THE
ALLEGED WRONGS IN GEORGIA.
THEY WERE SEVERE.
AND THAT PROSECUTOR HAS ALREADY
ISSUED 16 TARGET LETTERS TO FAKE
ELECTORS.
THAT SUGGESTS THAT SHE IS MOVING
MORE QUICKLY.
SHE SAID THAT SHE WOULD LIKE TO
WRAP UP THIS YEAR.
WE MAY SEE SOMETHING FASTER ON
THE STATE LEVEL.
>> AND LET ME BRING THIS
QUESTION TO YOU, ELIE.
BETWEEN THOSE INVESTIGATIONS,
WHO DO YOU THINK IS BETTER
SITUATED LEGALLY TO CRIMINALLY
CHARGE A FORMER PRESIDENT IF
THAT WERE TO HAPPEN?
>> THAT IS A JOB FOR DOJ IN MY
VIEW POLITICALLY, PRACTICALLY
AND LEGALLY.
AND LET ME EXPLAIN WHY.
FIRST OF ALL, DOJ HAS VASTLY
SUPERIOR RESOURCES AND
EXPERTISE.
THEY HAVE OVER 10,000 FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS, THE ENTIRE FBI AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT APPARATUS.
FULTON COUNTY D.A., I ADMIRE THE
EFFORT BUT THEY HAVE A GRAND
TOTAL OF ABOUT 50 ATTORNEYS AND
THEY DON'T SPECIAL LIIZE IN COMX
FRAUD CASES.
BUT IF A COUNTY D.A. TRIES TO
INDICT A FORMER PRESIDENT, FIRST
MOVE THAT FORMER PRESIDENT WILL
MAKE IS TO GO TO THE FEDERAL
COURT AND SAY NO, NO, YOU CAN'T
DO THAT UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ELECTED PARTISAN
LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL D.A.s
INDICTING PEOPLE FOR ANYTHING
THAT TOUCHES ON THE PRESIDENCY.
I KNOW NORM WILL SAY, YEAH, BUT
THAT ARGUMENT DOESN'T GFLY HERE
BUT WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE IT HAS
NEVER BEEN RAISED.
NO ONE HAS EVER TRIED TO INDICT
A FORMER PRESIDENT.
AND BEYOND DISPUTE, THAT IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT CAN ONLY BE MADE
AGAINST A COUNTY LEVEL D.A., NOT
AGAINST D.O.J.
SO THAT IS WHY DOJ ONLY HAS THE
INSTITUTIONAL CREDIBILITY AND I
THINK LEGAL STANDING TO MAKE
THIS KIND OF CASE.
>> NORM, HE TEED IT UP FOR YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE FINAL THOUGHT.
>> ELIE, IF DOJ HAS SUPERIOR
RESOURCES, WHY IS FANI WILLIS SO
FAR AHEAD OF THEM INCLUDING
THOSE 16 TARGET LETTERS?
THE REASON HE KNOWS WHAT I'LL
SAY ABOUT HIS LEGAL WRINKLE IS
BECAUSE HE AND I HAVE OFTEN
DISCUSSED IT OFF CAMERA.
THERE IS NO FEDERAL IMMUNITY FOR
A PURELY POLITICAL ATTEMPT TO
INTERFERE WITH AN ELECTION.
AND YOU LEFT OUT AN IMPORTANT
POINT, MY FRIEND.
AND HE IS MY VERY GOOD FRIEND.
WE CONSIDER OURSELVES THE
GENERAL COUNSEL DEPARTMENT FOR
ANA.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> ON THE POLITICAL FRONT,
PROSECUTOR IN ATLANTA IS MUCH
FURTHER AWAY FROM JOE BIDEN.
MERRICK GARLAND AND DOJ ARE IN
MORE APPROXPROXIMITY, SO THERE
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE IN MOVING IN
GEORGIA.
SHE IS DAERMDIS DETERMINED PROS
SHE HAS BROUGHT CASES LIKE THIS
BEFORE LIKE THE ATLANTA TEACHERS
SCANDAL AND I THINK THAT SHE
WILL DO THE JOB.